elon sport twitter neil should he be
spending his time and money taking
people to mars what's going on
yeah i've stopped
passing judgment on what billionaires do
with their money i mean think about it
he could just be
having a yacht contest for who has the
biggest yacht you know billionaires have
whatever are their habits and i don't
know that any of us would behave any
differently if we had billions of
dollars so i've just stopped commenting
on
what a billionaire
billionaires do do or should do with
their money what i can say
is
if a billionaire is going to do
something
it's kind of interesting that he
single-handedly brought electric cars
back into
uh
he created a new expectation for the
automotive industry basically
single-handedly and he reinvented
commercial rocket launch
so he's doing that with his billions and
he has 44 billion left over and he wants
to own twitter which he likes
all right uh i don't see anything wrong
with that by the way
most things out there have ceos who you
don't know
and you don't even ask we just happen to
know who the new ceo of twitter is about
to be and so now this becomes a point of
conversation
why isn't anybody talking about the head
of any other organization or company or
or strategic
platforms of communication
so
i think the level of scrutiny
is is
unjustified given
how much scrutiny we could be giving to
so many other things but that being said
if he does what everyone fears
especially on the left that he reopens
the floodgates gives trump an account
again um
i think we need to perhaps look at it a
different way
free speech is a
what you want is
to not suppress the speech that you
don't like but amplify the speech that
you do
and let
that be the
the arena
of contest
of ideas
because
if you suppress
ideas
those ideas will still always be there
and they'll run around saying i have
this idea but these folks don't want to
hear it that's very different from you
losing the idea game in an open contest
and then you say well how come nobody's
listening to you yeah because they
turned me off
because they they shut off the the
channels where i was communicating
because they don't want to hear anything
that i have to say or because everything
i said is wrong
all right these are two different ways
emerging truths can win but you want it
to be the second way because then no one
has a platform left
if it's a platform that is either
regressive
um
uh uh
puts us all at an existential risk or
whatever let it lose on its own terms
speaking of existential risks how good
do you think mars is as a backup to
humanity one of the problems what you
want to back up well the fact that we
only have one cradle at the moment right
if something goes wrong here if we're
all being slowly turned into paper clips
or grey goo or there's a
bio weapon that gets released or
whatever
we don't have some air-gapped backup
but i assume your listeners know what
you mean when you save world getting
turned into paper clips yes they do
they do so they're ai fluent is that
correct the ai fluent yeah that's all
one word as well ai fluent yes yeah they
are so they know nick bostrom they know
about existential risk hypothesis yes so
so
um
yeah or an asteroid or a virus whatever
or anything
yeah so so here's my
rebuttal to that
and by the way this rebuttal is
i don't know many people who have this
rebuttal so this may just be an outlier
in the examples you're collecting
but
right now antarctica
is wetter and balmier
than any place on mars
yet i don't see people lining up to
build condominiums there
all right it's a wholly inhospitable
place
right now it's used for some tourism but
mostly for scientific research
if you want to move to mars
and do it in a way that's not having you
confined to a habitat module you'll want
to terraform mars
and that's turning
mars into earth
and then ship a billion people there so
here's my thought
if
you have the power of geoengineering
to turn mars into earth
then no matter what is about to happen
on earth no matter what did happen on
earth you have the power to turn earth
back into earth
and so i don't see mars as in realistic
backup plan
because whatever you'd have to do to
mars you could do to earth and then
that's your backup plan on earth would
it be more difficult to terraform mars
than to perhaps survive a huge asteroid
impact or to combat no no no no you
deflect the asteroid what dude we're
talking
if we can fly to mars and terraform it
like fly to mars ship a billion people
there i think we'll know how to deflect
an asteroid okay okay am i
am i on a limb there when i don't think
that you are but my point is that there
may be some existential risks which are
so existential or so difficult to
overcome that the mars terraforming
could be easier than it would be one
that i can think of at this moment but
yes i will allow that possibility but
there is none i can think of
okay so how about a killer virus that
will take us off let's invent an
antiviral serum that'll take out
antivirus all right that's is that a
stretch to imagine
it's less of a stretch than flying to
mars terraforming it and shipping a
billion people there
fair enough no matter what you come up
with it's less of a stretch of my
imagination as a problem to solve
than terraforming margins ship a billion
people there that's how big the problem
is to do it
yeah the mars problem is because we
don't know how to terraform yet
we don't know how to terraform we i
think we could build the habitat module
sure we can figure that out
um
yeah but how many people are going to
live there and you have to bring
supplies you have to have supply ships
so but still to do that
there's a lot of science and technology
and time and money
just solve the problems here on earth
just solve them
so you're saying that elon buying
twitter actually is the best use of his
money rather than his attention rather
than going to mars
oh no no i'm not i i i will not judge
what people should or should not do with
their money
okay yeah so i will not say i'm glad he
did this or that what i will say
is and by the way 44 billion is a
is it
fifteen percent of his wealth
twenty percent of his work he's raised
it from investors as well yeah yeah yeah
so
so
um and by the way that wealth it's not
like he doesn't have that money anymore
it's invested in a thing that has value
so it's not like you went to buy candy
and you ate the candy and you don't have
the money anymore so
so
i'm not gonna sit here and pass judgment
on how billionaires spend their money
i'm just not going to do that
i can tell you he wants to terraform
mars
i don't have a problem with that but if
you're doing it because you think earth
needs a backup plan that's the wrong
reason that's that's kind of objectively
false
it's not let me say that differently
it's hard to defend it for that reason
you can defend it for other reasons it's
a cool thing to do the technology
demonstration sure
but if you're gonna say
we need to put our eggs in two baskets
instead of one
so that when a disaster hits one planet
everyone else can just watch it and
watch half their species die and somehow
be okay with that rather than prevent it
from happening in the first place if
you're okay with that then fine
but i'm saying
fix the problems that you don't even
have that solution you're trying to that
pro that problem you're trying to escape
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace